you
at any second now under the Bern
tournament that's my test I gotta get
back over back got a mouse lip got me
good on a mouse lip rook d7 there's no
way I would have played rook d7 no way
they already moved they already moved a
four uh-huh
I'm on that square let's do this they're
gonna play e5 mm-hmm I'm regretting my
decision I'm gonna break again it's
Castle before it's too late
it might already be too late Glenny
exchange quite sure what that
does maybe Queen b3 yeah Queen b3 to
defend my night because there's
potential sacrifices here with the rook
that's maybe what they're eyeing up
let's kick him away mmm
that is painful rook here rook back if
they don't take my bishop seems very
passive and it is God defend my Brooke
Oh gonna play like that is that right
the Queen Oh Queen exchange okay maybe
this isn't so bad actually look at the
time look at the time I had them
thinking they went into the think tank
tricky night they only have two seconds
that was a blunder I don't have any time
they're down a piece now back to
tournament at 19 seconds okay well yeah
you know they that happens sometimes you
get in such a good position where you
know there's just too many good
continuations man I have
what a wonderful pick of variations here
let me think a few seconds and then
before you know it it all adds up and
you got no gas left you're playing on e0
okay I've been here before in a slower
game let's see how they react all right
I wanna put pressure on e5 I'm gonna
take know King is not a knight let's
take here and then here
they're gonna give a queen check nope
Bishop d7 a little dance get ready for
the dance he belongs over here Knight f3
would get pinned my LightSquared Bishop
is a monster
the unopposed bishop let's put him in
somewhere enough light square I guess
probably a five I don't know how to
proceed on this side of the board
fish of h4 let's break it these pawns a
little bit just a little bit put
pressure on this guy
officer collar Bishop ending maybe put
my bishop here keep the tension defend
that pawn actually I didn't even realize
I was defending the pawn
actually you know I'm gonna lose this
guy g3 I'm in trouble
fortunately I have some time let's go
here look two double and then take
strong bishop my bishops playing and
their bishop is and I also control b1
you get to the B file let's do that
could I do have anything in this rank
here let's grab this pawn get to the
second there in a pin pin point g2 g2
mate threat light square is collapsing
there in a pin still pigs I don't have
any time either he's done anything
they're down in time back to Turman in
time cubed zero three three he's in at a
six a lot of fours okay we have 40
players now Knight f3 wonderful bullet
opening alright we're gonna build in the
center and then have this pawn become an
inconvenience maybe okay clean here here
we're looking for h2 stuff are we I need
my knight I really do it's important he
stays around to defend my knight here
get out of there get out okay now I have
to sweat a little bit defend h2
bishop here and that's so fast defend F
to Bishop f4 soon not so fast I could
hit the Queen and then back up and be in
a position to get rid of this Knight
actually not so fast the Queen is close
to trap she has to go back to f6 here
maybe I could have taken that is an
illegal move get out of there I'm gonna
take on f2 or allow me to take on h5
yeah do this now let's get that in first
oh no I have this cover of my bishop huh
that was lucky Queen trap she's close to
being trapped let's get it let's get it
let's get on the same diagonals to
Bishop yeah get off of one diagonal but
go right on another yeah let's go here
and get out of pins okay it's still a
bit scary very loose position 16 seconds
I'm on the brook when are you going to
take that rook really my goodness
playing ridiculous Queen d5 check after
rook takes let's go here I'm on f5
alright for a trade the Queen's off
another exchange keep that pawn they're
not moving push this Knight out of here
check here now just take the tricky
night before he hurts you back to
tournament 10 no 12 12 10 8 8 8
ok hmm plenty of time left in this one I
have to make sure I don't read okay what
was I gonna say I was gonna say if I get
paired up with Erica make sure you don't
resign
don't resign too early don't resign too
early
okay let's challenge the guy that's in
your position
threatening to win upon got it
and I also have a central majority so
let's set that into motion probably do
that no matter what mm-hmm
unless that move is played okay let's
keep pressure on g2 let's grab that pine
there light squares are collapsing now
take a pond on a light square light
square issues let's see if they help me
to move forward
maybe my knight gets into f3 I want to
keep the Queen's on their king is more
vulnerable i takes h2 is a serious
problem
rook is hit and that is mate whoa light
square weaknesses 15 12 12 11 hmm okay
all right yeah less than 22 phobic again
let's try e4 and let's try something
other than the exchange Cairo okay
you're gonna give me all right let's try
to hunt down maybe 95 or night h4 let's
get some more development in yeah let's
try this maybe 95 sooner would have been
better
mm-hmm I'm freeing up f4 this is good
I'm in exchange Knights and then here
don't do anything crazy okay f5 let's
break this down let's see how they
approach this let's do this first here
uh-huh
let's go here I have a queen exchange
that's how they make a decision Queen b6
let's expand some I want to keep this
tension so much for that I want to play
here they're going to take and play see
four
should do this ah let's just kick him
away and then reposition my knight
not so fast let's do this move wow it's
really close I want to exchange off
LightSquared bishop s' I'm not sure
where my knight is why did I allow that
ah the rooks gonna have an O then moving
the knight in the plane rook 84 would
have been excellent for them you know
they tried to get that in okay let's
play on this side of the board now I'm
taking how okay
let's come over here what's my clean
doing get her over here please exchange
Queens hang on run stop that pawn from
pushing enter my bishop and get over
here
Queens are off and they're down on time
back to tournament hmm twenty nineteen
sixteen eleven less than twenty minutes
in this one okay let's keep going
ooh I think we're gonna get paired up
because his game just finished nope I am
staking mainline novelty let's stay out
of any main lines I don't know what am I
saying
just move ah yeah just allow their
LightSquared bishop to come out that
freely
why don't you don't set any problems for
black really you're playing with the
white pieces and what do you do you
throw your advantage right away well
done well done maybe we can make use of
this square though maybe he could be
dangerous let's take care Queen b3
that's a good way to get your knight
trapped you realize that
yeah my nights ready to be trapped he's
really close to being trapped how do I
save him how do I save a night okay
maybe like this push this guy and then
okay I could get into this square now
here and then maybe as a pawn sack now
Queen coming over here and then this
square starting to generate threats in
fact Knight takes pawn would have been
good let's do it now King f8 I just back
up and maintain pressure on the night
mmm
yeah let's go here actually I'm gonna
push here maybe Knight back over hits
the Queen in no g7 so this is crushing
this is mate back to tournament that
night on f5 is super strong twenty eight
twenty twenty thirteen he's running away
with it one two three four four berserks
four wins with berserks one extra game
in 17 minutes remain okay I don't think
no I haven't played this guy before
let's try the Sicilian as our purpose
don't correct me don't even how many of
you are ready to just go ahead and start
typing away it's not pronounced like
that let's stop g4 put a halt to a quick
expansion in the Kings side maybe
that'll buy me some time to do something
over here on the Queen side let's go
here stop c5 stuff and yeah help you
know maybe I should have inserted this
check first let's castle back up push
this guy stop knight here
Bishop f6 connect my rooks well my
wrecks are connected let's go here
actually watch out for this move uh-oh
okay I might be alright with that
defense or not let's see I get this move
at the end
uh-huh let's do this and then here they
have a passed pawn pretty scary hmm here
here offer Queen exchange I have good
coordination don't know what to make of
this ending Queens off I think is good
for me I think I have to approach just a
little bit guard against Queen h4 all
right mm-hmm
yeah it's a bit scary a little bit scary
I have to defense a lot of squares
around my king keep pressure on g3 we
throw in a check ooh I got this and the
rook with check maybe here
Queen trade okay
these guys should be good
taking that pond sooner okay okay now
it's definitely winning but look at my
time can't breathe Oh me oh I have to
get those pre moves down better it's a
draw
hmm that's that hurts that hurts that's
a street killer a street killer what is
that about taking him I'm taking him and
yeah you're gonna hit me with something
clean 84 okay that maybe capture first
and then queen there so they're getting
the pawn back but I don't know just play
with this I don't want to take I don't
want to take and invite a piece forward
so this is a fine group of pawns Castle
let's throw a question to him soon it's
also good for flight square right here
half-opened file should probably expand
this is covered yeah they missed that I
resign No yeah fine with exchanges rook
takes and what more can I do just want
to simplify they resigned back
determined 45 45 24 24 2013 minutes
remain no one's nicked him flawless with
yeah four or five berserks gotta play
against the troll account who is vers
arcing me all right catch them in Primos
have them think early
mm-hmm okay on the rook at the end of
this actually night here is mate back to
Terman who had a maid earlier but on the
f3 square
Anton cubed a nice little play off of a
catchphrase from some time ago okay
Space Invader let's go here b3 there
should be 2 how to capture I'm gonna
take with this guy so Bishop f5 doesn't
hit Bishop g4 let's rule that out
mm-hmm what's the story here panic a
break oh that's the story this might
still be good yeah it is
maybe not um I'm not sure to do let's go
here I want to get the dark square
Bishop they're giving me a problem
though wow they're still giving me a
problem okay finally I could take him
but they're doing that now do I not have
this move I do
and then this so I get the Queen maybe
played a little too fast there maybe I
have checks if the knight moves like
this very important and let's take the
tricky Knight
if you have the option take that tricky
night I get Bishop here
let's check offer an exchange or look
for me you could also look for checkmate
it's also pretty reasonable option yeah
just just get test that just could test
the open file yeah think positional
think positional don't think making one
okay all right yeah position on this all
right we've been here before
in that game I ran out of time with I
had a good position let's see if we go
down the same path with the knight
jumping in here and
a structural change okay so let's get
here he knows his place we do have the
same thing I'm pointing at c2 now they
defend let's and develop my queen over
here this could be uncomfortable on
Knight a5 move on 95 I do have bishop
our rook to c7 to defend and still have
him act aggressively so now we're gonna
take and start looking at the h2 square
maybe mm-hmm let's do this first maybe
sneak my queen into these squares she
also has some lateral movement I want to
do this I have the h3 square that I
think I can rely upon if Bishop f2 now
here not so fast actually let's stop
what it is they want to do castle I
don't know that I want to castle I like
my rook on the H file now we're going to
take and then play here Knight f3 I take
here and that was actually already a
threat rook here I have a fork let's do
this I want to be able to play here on
rook f1 and not allow Luke f7 with check
King here would have allowed that so
this and now contest this file we're
doing all right on the clock
rook exchange is avoided I improved my
rip position improved my King position
and then track boo and then drop a rook
I get the knight back fortunately and
they don't have time at the end of the
day okay just push this guy they'll
never see it coming
never back determine 53:34 26 slow him
down man somebody somebody slow him down
what oh my goodness what just happened
there Knight G 1 2 F 3 F 3 2 G 1
something everybody should try at least
once in their chess playing career at
once at least once
that one is called the night shuffle
variation he did a little shuffle the
night Juke variation he was trying to
Juke black I got to stop with b5 advance
it's not really stopped let's let's
launch upon over here
I didn't like f3 oh that's a freebie
that's a free pun take once yeah let's
go here let's open it up all right
I feel like throwing my knight in here
let's do it
it seems really good let's get rid of
this nutty I could have taken here mate
in two it would have been still back on
and this is collapsing let's check and
that's going to be mate they resigned
back to tournament 53:38 2826 son
thorium c5 I guess and let's look to put
some pressure here hmm play this already
earlier in the stream a blitz game okay
mmm let's go here Queen c7 let's
challenge the dark square Bishop Bishop
g5 I have this they might take advantage
of my knight here though here I do this
move though fork is still present two
minor pieces two minor pieces for the
rook something on h2 let's back up a
light square Bishop just defend him
Queen exchange take towards the center
reposition my knight soon kick him out
of here you have the bishops also I'm
going to clamp down and there advance
with the beep on Bishop here you know
have really good control here yeah I
should have done this one move sooner
actually Bishop c5 opposite their King
you know look to control all these
squares here
let's take the night and then take here
I'm winning some material approve the
King actually let's stay here I wanted
to keep a rook on the board still my
bishop needs to improve let's get here
defend that pawn he's important don't
let the rook attacked it was the name of
the game
get out of there rook get out of the pin
improve the bishop how about I start
expanding I'm expanding at the wrong
moment I had the square covered let's
push Oh fortunately fortunately
fortunately I had that move now these
pawns should just win it all should box
the King out a little bit they don't
have any time they don't have any time
only realizing that now back determine
less than five minutes remain
ooh someone finally nicked him well done
whoever you are fifty five forty two
thirty eight thirty keep going
oh we're paired up I gotta try and beat
him oh really is that we gonna try to do
okay yeah let's get a pawn in the center
let's see how they address this pressure
here against their Center mmm
don't want to invest the bishop pair and
get upon exchange light square bishop I
make that happen c4 they don't have an
in-betweener do they here bishop here
hmm gotta guard the g5 square I think at
least break it b3 they're trying to hurt
me they're definitely trying to hurt me
I have Knight f8 though do I not and I
could always defend with my queen take
this pawn probably should have
which this pond how about I'm in a good
position no doubt I'm actually
threatening to take this pond I just
dropped my knight why would you drop
your knight like that give a check of my
knight defend uh-huh how about I just
get pushing these guys here first and
then push uh-huh I want to get a queen
trade thank you
get the Queen's off at least gotta start
pushing these guys uh-huh it's tricky
tricky tricky tricky you're pushing this
guy finally okay a lot of way too much
counter play here okay and I don't have
much time and I get this guy pushing
okay I really had to go about it this
way he's gonna hide behind that pawn get
out of here pawn you're no good to me
pawn you're no good you're no good oh
man down on time man oh man I mean that
would I don't think hmm yeah that
wouldn't have helped score wise in the
tournament but man you couldn't win
he was speaky that was a sneaky King
he's like I just hide behind your pawn
your major pieces will never get me you
know how it works
everyone's experience that everyone
everyone who's played chess has
experienced that there's no way around
it it's one of those positions where you
just you don't want your pawn because
he's just in the way
Oh am i frustrated absolutely not okay
come on sacrifice the peace with you how
they get know that pin let's see let's
see how are you gonna do it
take him out play here and then here and
watch out for each seven oh my goodness
very scary I'm on the night this game is
so intense man
so intense it really is less than a
minute in the tournament less than a
minute got the Queen that's a check here
no matter what get to f3 would you
where's the knight gone he's having a
tough day tough day for the night let's
take him out not be so fast to invest
too much material all right let's give
some back like this guy make sure let's
get him to just push okay any pawns
gonna get in my way this time back
determine oh you withdrew what's that
about 5646 39 38 how does that work yeah
you could just withdraw early and be
like yeah I don't need to do much more
I'll just I'll catch it the podium I'll
catch it the podium my work here is done
alright and that is it GG's 5646 39:38
is where we finished 51 players at the
end competed already good games oh nice
you